creepy joe trending on twitter after a
truly bizarre moment when president
biden
aggressively whispered into a microphone
viewer warning it's pretty weird
you said when people are waiting for
relief
i got them 1.9 trillion dollars relief
so far
they're going to be getting checks in
the mail that are consequential
this week for child care just remind
them i wrote the bill
on the environment why would i not be
for it
pay them more
this is an employee's
employee's bargaining chip now
what's happening so greg i just imagine
joe biden doing the whisper thing while
he's touching
or sniffing someone's hair no
i don't know does he know that everyone
can hear him like generally when you
whisper i couldn't hear him when you
whisper it's so people can't hear you
but he's when he's whispering everybody
can hear him because he's got a
microphone
look um it's one thing to whis like
why is he doing this because he's
pretending that he's stating something
that is obvious
right pay them more except that's a
really stupid comment
it's kind of stupid really dumb it's
like it's it that's not the
beginning and the end of an opinion
although he would be
really great as a character in a horror
movie i was discussing this earlier
that if they ever do um a horror film
that takes place in an abandoned library
and there's this backstory where there
was a male librarian
who had been like uh attacked by crazed
kids
and he was left to die and then he but
he's still there and then like years
later these other kids
show up at the library and it's
they call it whispering joe sounds like
a great
rose something out of a hot like
hogwarts he could be like
yeah yes right you could come right in
whispering at you
with the wand maybe jessica or they
could also call the movie
good old joe right because this is a
habit that he has apparently you've done
your research
well i like to come prepared yeah
oh are you saying we're not prepared i
am i love you
i insulted you well not the girls
babies so
i did my research on it it's something
that he does but i think
that we can all agree as adults and have
children there
there's a large contingency of americans
mostly democrats some moderate
republicans
independents who find joe biden charming
and this is part of his
charm it's part of his thing i mean i
watched donald trump do that weird dance
like on the stage at rallies
i don't think that it's a donald trump v
joe biden
spelling bee well it would rate well but
it's just who joe biden is and people
like him yeah jesse
or martha this happened with president
trump right like you know hours of
morning tv like there's something wrong
with this many people
we need to have him psychologically
analyzed he's unstable he's unfit
and that that's what that's what i just
find like you know that for me that's
the whole thing like you want people to
sort of treat
things in some kind of equal semblance
and manner but every time he does
something weird it's like no one's
allowed to talk about it every time he
looks
so exhausted that you're afraid that
like you know he might fall down
we're not like no one's allowed to talk
about it but in the past presidency it
was like fair game all the time so why
is that
well i think he was in a good mood
yesterday because he thought he cut a
deal which ended up not being a deal but
at the time he thought he cut a deal and
was happy
and he's not a very articulate guy i'm
not talking about his stutter i'm
talking about in the history of
presidents
he's not an effective communicator he's
not known to be a persuasive guy
he doesn't speak in a clear and concise
way and he gets frustrated
so he has three tells the first tell is
come on man
and that's joe giving up that's joe
knowing he can't convince you with an
actual sentence it's just
come on man and then the other tell is
the anger
the finger the wagging and the flash of
the temper that's when he gets
frustrated that he's not communicating
the third tell is the whisper the
whisper is joe
lowering his cadence because he never
does that because he's very boring he
lowers his cadence and he comes down
and he tries to reassure the audience
that everything is okay
i have things under control i'm cutting
a deal i'm doing a great job
and that's the way a limited guy like
joe biden communicates sometimes
and i hate to agree with you jessica
it's one of the more endearing things he
does
well you know what he says he says speak
softly and carry a life alert
good one hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else